[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi
14 mars
la 21e édition du printemps des poètes a
commencé mercredi
comme chaque année les itinéraires
poétique vous le poursuivre dans toute
l'agglomération reportage au sens du
premier atelier dans cette édition de
ville de loisirs à la tour eiffel pour
sensibiliser à l'éco-responsabilité
c'est le douzième eco trail de paris
ville de 80km s'élance samedi depuis
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
l'organisateur des courtes sera avec
nous faut les chocs d'elancourt le club
de roller hockey vous convie à sa
traditionnelle disco roller du printemps
avec pour thématique la saint-patrick
vous pourrez glisser en faire face dès
ce samedi 16 mars le 21e printemps des
poètes a commencé mercredi 13 mars
comme chaque année les structures
culturelles de saint quentin en yvelines
se mobilisent pour vous amener de la
poésie une édition en beauté c'est le
thème de cette année
mélanie poquet s'est rendu au tout
premier atelier à la médiathèque du
canal de montigny le bretonneux un
reportage raconter comme un poème
interprétation poétique en musique une
entrée dans l'univers de la poésie pour
tous sans besoin d'études de sémantique
le printemps des poètes vous plonge dans
toutes ses fantaisies cet après-midi-là
atelier vient on va voir des poètes
on propose à tant de scènes ouvertes
voilà chacun vient adultes enfants
adolescents lire un texte qu'il a envie
de lire une vingtaine de lieux sont
investis sur l'ensemble du festival une
quarantaine d'intervenants pour vous
faire aimer la musique le langage des
mots qui partent à l'international et
permet au public saint quentinois un peu
de vagabondage
c'est mon fils qui a des origines
marchiennes s'est demandé si le
raconteur d'histoires par les marocains
parce que les prestations de son qu'il a
reconnus du marocain c'est très
inattendu je ne m'attendais pas du tout
à ça et je juge très surprise et très
touché des amoureux de la poésie
passionnés qui vous plonge dans leur
univers inspiré ce que nous proposons
par moments changement de la musique
et puis l'enchantement des gens qui sont
autour de nous c'est vraiment ce retour
aux origines de cette rencontre entre la
poésie et l'être humain des rencontres
poétiques sous toutes ses formes la
commanderie accueille le tout premier
village du mot le dernier week-end pour
terminer en grande forme performance
conférences expositions et ateliers vous
pouvez vous le notez en mai vous
dimanche 17 mars commence le printemps
du cinéma
l'occasion de faire le plein de toiles à
petit tarif patrick jane de dixmude
s'est renseigné sur la programmation du
grenier à sel pour votre rubrique dans
les salles saint-quentinoise
[Musique]
nous l'avons tous remarqué le printemps
arrive et le printemps arrive aussi dans
les salles de cinéma donc dimanche 17
lundi 18 et mardi 19 mars 2019
les séances sont à 4 euros au grenier à
sel nous vous proposons la favorite
nous proposons aussi minuscule grâce à
dieu et weiss qui sont les quatre films
à l'affiché pendant le printemps du
cinéma
[Musique]
autre information importante
il va y avoir prochainement des travaux
dans le cadre de l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 et ils auront lieu autour
du grenier à sel le cinéma sera donc
difficilement accessible en journée il y
aura en plus des nuisances donc
au jour d'aujourd'hui je connais pas
encore la date de démarrage des travaux
mais soyez prévenus que en journée il
n'y aura pas de séance publique
à part les séances commenceront donc
commenceront à 18 heures en semaine et
auront lieu toute la journée dans le
week end
[Musique]
les chineurs noteront ce grand rendez
vous la foire de chatou démarre vendredi
15 jusqu'au 24 mars plus d'une semaine
pour chasser des trésors et découvrir
une exposition spéciale sur raymond
poulidor pareil pas pareil c'est le
thème de la deuxième édition de la
semaine de la petite enfance les crèches
et relais d'assistantes maternelles de
maurepas se mobilisent pour vous
proposer plusieurs ateliers vous pouvez
vous inscrire auprès des structures
[Musique]
depuis plus de dix ans il vous fait
courir dans une démarche d'éco
responsabilité l'eco-trail revient à
paris plusieurs courses dont la plus
longue de 80 km qui part de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
avec nous un plateau romain piot bonjour
bonjour vous êtes organisateur de
l'événement oncle au départ a lieu
samedi à 12h15 c'est bon tout est prêt
tout est prêt ça fait un an qu'on
travaille dessus et il ne reste plus
maintenant un peu plus de 24 heures mais
tout est prêt on devrait pouvoir
accueillir ses 2700 participants dans
les parfaites conditions où justement il
ya beaucoup d'inscrits cette année c'est
un record on est sur un record sur le
trail 80 avec plus de 1700 participants
et au total on à 11500 trader ce qui est
un record depuis depuis la toute
première édition en 2008 alors l'eco
trail comme sous de l'indic ce n'est pas
une course ordinaire est lent dans une
démarche de sensibilisation à l'éco
responsabilité est ce que vous expliquer
un peu en quoi cela consiste
oui tout à fait donc notre projet et
notre ambition depuis le début c'est
d'une part de prouver qu'il est possible
d'organiser un événement de masse donc
là on va accueillir plus de douze mille
participants au total
c'est possible d'organiser un événement
de masse en respectant un cahier des
charges est coresponsable très strictes
et aussi l'ambition pouvoir sensibiliser
et éduquer tous nos coureurs a des
principes et des actions très concrètes
d'éco responsabilité comme par exemple
trier les déchets comme par exemple
aussi amener son gobelet sur les
ravitaillements pour pouvoir s'hydrater
c'est tout un tas d'actions qu'on leur
propose
sud éducation donc ça dès 2008 et même
son concept qui s'est exporté dans
l'europe
exactement même encore plus loin en fait
la toute première édition à cette
exporté c'était à bruxelles en belgique
maintenant on est sur 12 eco trail en
europe et aussi en asie puisqu'on vient
d'annoncer des eco trail en malaisie en
thaïlande
donc on va être à 12 et cotrade
maintenant en 2019 toujours sur le même
principe d'éco responsabilité et
d'ouverture et découverte de la pratique
du trail au plus grand nombre
toujours avec ce cahier des charges très
strict vous avez présenté quelques
règles en a d'autres oui il y en a
d'autres
on veut aussi faire une sensibilisation
à l'utilisation des transports doux donc
tous les participants ont un ticket de
transport qui leur permettre de prendre
le train pour accéder aux zones de
départ de transport doux c'est la
mobilité douce donc s'il est le rr les
navettes aussi les trains de la sncf
pour pouvoir accéder sur la zone du
départ 80 monsieur du 45 et du 30 km
alors le départ de la course phare donc
le 80 kilomètres ça se fait à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines où
100 des parts festif l'agglomération a
même proposé au groupe scara bande de
mettre l'ambiance musicale varin un
événement autour de ce départ oui tout à
fait c'est toujours une grande fête
parce que faire partir de 1700 coureurs
qui s'apprête à faire 80 km c'est
toujours un événement et on aura aussi
là
l'occasion de pouvoir faire un départ
fictif avec l'association une lame pour
courir avec brice marmonnier notamment
qui avec des enfants fera un départ
anticipé
c'est aussi pour nous l'occasion de
montrer que le trail c'est ouvert aux
gens aux coureurs sportifs valides mais
aussi les personnes en situation
d'handicap parce qu'il perd important
pour nous justement si vous voulez plus
d'informations sur une lame pour corps
et vous pouvez voir le jt d'hier donc
c'était mercredi en replay sur notre
site internet
donc merci commun d'être notre plateau
le départ du 80 km 6 samedi à 12h15 pour
une arrivée au trocadéro à paris tous
les renseignements sur le site internet
eco trail
autre événement sportif vert mais pour
d'autres raisons cette fois la
traditionnelle disco roller du club des
longs cours
cette animation du printemps vous
propose une thématique saint patrick
enfilez vos patins et vos chemises très
cela quatre feuilles de façade et pour
vous lancer sur la piste en musique et
en lumière
l'inscription se fait directement sur
place rendez vous samedi 16 mars de 17h
à 21h au gymnase chaste amis à elancourt
le président du club au micro de manon
par aldo plein discours l'heure c'est
c'est une soirée patinage en fête ou
un événement familial où les gens
viennent donc entre amis en famille pour
patiner en musique et
et en lumière parce qu'on aura sur fond
de lumière également et donc c'est ce 16
mars en début de soirée on va partir de
17h l'objectif c'est que tout le monde
se retrouve dans un moment assez festif
et s'amusent ensemble sur 7 sur cette
soirée est donc on prévoit également du
snack de la buvette etc pour que tout le
monde puisse vraiment passé quatre
heures ici de façon sympa
dans le cadre de la semaine consacrée à
l'égalité femmes hommes de plaisir le
conservatoire de l'aser le propose un
atelier danse père enfants animé par
nathalie brissonnet il est ouvert aux
enfants de 6 à 8 ans et leur papa pour
une matinée de complicité sur des pas de
danse pour ce week-end village des
futurs insolites des 11 et 12 mai la
commanderie en appel à vos meilleurs aux
inventions crever vous les méninges et
envoyer leurs vos projets et idées
novatrices
que vous soyez entrepreneurs artistes
bricoleurs du dimanche ou enfants pleins
d'imagination vous serez peut-être
sélectionnés pour leur exposition autres
et peut être une position à paris pour
voyager jusque en océanie le musée du
quai branly accueille l'exposition
océanie partez explorer les arts de
toutes les civilisations du pacifique
une rétrospective de leur histoire et de
leur savoir-faire à découvrir jusqu'au 7
juillet maylis car was de nos confrères
via grand parent et voyager au coeur de
l'histoire d'un peuple d'explorateurs
naviguer dans une multitude d'îles
paradisiaques sur les eaux profondes de
l'océanie une région unique et mystique
qui abrite les perles artistique ici
deux cents pièce raconte l'héritage des
peuples insulaires des trésors en
hommage au savoir-faire ancestral
relatif sur les croyances animistes des
autochtones
on est dans une région du monde qui
représentent quasiment un tiers de la
surface du globe
quand les premiers hommes franchissent
la première fois à bord de radeaux ce
petit bras de mer qui sépare alors les
deux plaques continentales de saül
soldats des gens issus d'asie du sud est
qui partent en pirogue à la conquête du
pacifique les gens avec une connaissance
du milieu marin désastre des oiseaux ils
ont pu repérer des chemins et les
emprunter pour peupler le pacifique à
travers les siècles les arts d'océanie
se sont développés grâce à des pratiques
des changes les transactions avec une
obligation de retour synonyme
d'affluence et de prestige malgré le
pillage de l' empire colonial et la
conversion au christianisme des peuples
autochtones
une multitude d'objets ont pu être
conservés et retrouver les petits
trésors méconnus mais qui nous en disent
plus sur les arts du pacifique
alors c'est une exposition événement par
sa capacité à avoir réuni autant de
pièces il n'y a jamais eu d'exposition
en france qui aborde le pacifique en
entier pour toute sa diversité et tout
ce qu'il lit ses traditions artistiques
dans leur intégralité tant qu'il s'agit
du pacifique insulaire et dans toute
leur diversité pour les pièces
historiques et contemporaines
la dernière partie de l'exposition
interroge sur les défis contemporains
à l'avenir les îles du pacifique
pourrait disparaître elles sont menacées
par le réchauffement climatique et la
montée des eaux
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 7
juillet et c'est la fin de votre 7,8
choisir merci nous avoir celui n'abusez
pas trop du houblon pour la
saint-patrick ce dimanche
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles cd sorti
[Musique]
ouais
où
[Musique]